I'm 64 years old
ER and have been tending pashmina goats
and Yaks since I was a child
see
[Music]
I play Damian it helps to pass the time
while the livestock are grazing
I believe the melody helps to heal the
animals when they're sick
putting soil on the Frozen River makes
it easier for the goats to cross
otherwise they could slip and fall
as the weather gets warmer we see less
rain and snow and grazing lands are
shrinking it's causing diseases to
spread among the livestock
there isn't enough grazing land so the
goats aren't healthy and strong we
depend on supplementary food which is an
additional cost that we aren't able to
make up here
back in the day because of the cold
weather the pashmina goats used to have
fine wool
but now with the warmer temperatures the
quality is not as good
about 70 families used to live here
but most of them have migrated only 11
families are left
I'm planning to give up my nomadic life
I've sold half of my livestock and will
sell the rest in the coming days
[Music]
I will move to Leia for an easier life
but I will miss this land so physically
I will not be in kharnak my soul will
always remain here foreign